girl still enjoys women's hey I heard
though I'm gonna go a breath welcome
back to yo well go back to blood oh [ __ ]
this place
this is what I wanted to see just what
the [ __ ] are you
oh god like the moon that was the
easiest possible laughing so good game
this place is often I didn't go so well
didn't stop Oh white tonight gammon
joint
what was your name sorry Clara mine
alright
how we gonna do it is you want to cannon
up your ways hello hey hey no [ __ ] me
he's fast
you got my cannonball how ok ok it's
pretty good to do damage are you doing a
crowd of mine are you doing buddy
you want to cannonball in your ass hey
good move grandpa man you got the moves
ah [ __ ] you camper then don't hurt me
I'm scary I'm scared I mean what ah
[ __ ] hell
oh [ __ ] almost ice
stop [ __ ] shooting oh [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] tough oh god he's gonna
transform is he faster now oh god what
is that
okay cool
ooh that fart Edgar Jesus Christ man
well good job me had a man the first
hunter but I'm the last baby
how do I view so well the first time I
don't understand how that works
you
good fight good fight
damn oh my god I'm so [ __ ] tired
let's watch these ending out
it's my girlfriend telling me to stop
playing blood-borne
oh my god you're just as beautiful as I
remember love your hair
and now we're the next hunter
yep there we are that's pretty badass
the hunt begins again oh my god I love
this type of endings where the story
keeps going even though it's kind of sad
there you go beautiful oh man that last
boss was a lot more satisfying than the
will ending Dark Souls it was the same
type of fight
this woman was a lot harder but and when
I started as soon as I said Dark Soul is
my favorite game but I really think I
haven't played that much PvP though but
I really think blood-borne I like how
because personally I like how they went
from fantasy theme even though I love
fantasy to horror theme I think that was
so [ __ ] awesome I love horror so that
worked for me but not only how it
changed the theme from that but also how
that changed the gameplay I loved how it
became more aggressive and how they took
away the shield think it works super
well so more for me I love this so much
I thought it it's almost perfect
[ __ ] awesome yeah I can't wait to do
some PvP but I feel like my otherwise my
life is gonna be empty now because I
don't know what to do with it it's kind
of sad but it's been an epic epic
journey to share with you bros it's
[ __ ] insane how I can play my
favorite game and that's my job so
that's that's ridiculous and that's
possible thanks to you can't tell you
how much I appreciate it it's [ __ ]
awesome